difficultés dans les prises dans l'
annonce des prises de décisions au
niveau du couple préfets maires au
niveau de la gestion de crise par les
ars le rôle également avec les
préfectures ont pu al'inverse voir
aujourd'hui une annonce dans un région
qui m'est cher également de dépistage
massif mais de manière assez semble-t-il
décorrélée du travail avec les ars la
ceppm lettres l'habitude de tracking et
de solutions pour les patients mais
au-delà de ça je voulais justement avoir
votre ressenti par rapport à votre
regard par rapport à ce travail
justement conjointe avec les ars les
préfets les élus locaux durant les mois
de crise et puis quel est votre bilan
sur cet effort justement puisque nous je
parlais de dépistage massif cet effort
de dépistage massif que nous réalisons
depuis maintenant plusieurs mois avec
justement l'aide des ars des cpam et de
toutes les instances représentatives
je vous remercie bien merci beaucoup ce
que j'allais presque dire que les
questions sont tellement larges telles
qu'elles couvrent quasiment tout le
champ alors je vais quand même essayer
de répondre de façon synthétique dans la
première question comme la troisième
d'ailleurs sont plutôt rétrospective
puisque vous me demandez de de tirer un
bilan à grands traits de ce qui s'est
passé depuis plusieurs mois et notamment
de la façon dont les événements ont été
anticipées je me suis permis juste 2
vous les connaissez de porter une courbe
un petit graphique devant la commission
tout là je pense que tous les françaises
et français connaissent c'est à dire que
grosso modo depuis le déconfinement et
comment sont au moins au mois de juillet
c'est à dire ma prise de fonction en
qualité de premier ministre
on a effectivement une courbe des cours
là c'est plusieurs prix année les
couleurs excusez moi c'est des
différents pays mais je le tiens à la
disposition de la commission des courbes
qui évolue comme bien des mathématiciens
de façon linéaire et donc face à cette
linéarité
nous prenons là aussi comme la plupart
des pays qui nous entourent
des mesures on va dire un cocktail de
mesures
je reviendrai tout à l'heure sur le
dépistage et les tests et des mesures
dites de freinage 1 pour prendre bien
les deux catégories qui sont à la fois
adapté à l'évolution épidémique à partir
des critères dont nous disposons et le
plus de territorialiser possible je
pourrais rentrer dans tous les détails
de toutes les phases je le ferai tout à
l'heure si votre commission le soin donc
on maîtrise plus ou moins les affaires
c'est à dire que
on a des résultats dans certaines
régions vous souvenez de la mayenne vous
vous souvenez des mesures qu'on avait
commencé à prendre à bordeaux à
marseille
effectivement à nice on a des mesures de
freinage quelques petits résultats
et puis et puis brutalement donc quelque
part en octobre là ça change selon les
pays
ce produit pour des raisons que les
scientifiques eux-mêmes n'explique
pariès une très brutale accélération
dépit des très brutal qui nous prend à
tous je le dis à tous deux revers il ya
un petit décalage de jours on le voit
d'ailleurs encore aujourd'hui si on suit
de façon extrêmement précise
pays par pays la situation est
évidemment pas exactement la même dans
tous mais on a soudain une accélération
très forte qui aboutit à la dernière
carte européenne dont je dispose c'est à
dire le taux d'incidence sur 13 jours
glissants voilà donc qui fait que
l'europe selon les critères harmonisés
de la commission passe progressivement
si on avait eu il ya la même carte ya
huit jours le serait-elle un peu plus
varié dans la colorisation là maintenant
vous le voyez on est à peu près tous
malheureusement rattrapé par la flambée
donc il est clair il est clair la
réponse à votre question que entre il
était la preuve extrêmement difficile
d'anticiper cette brutale accélération
pandémique et j'observe du reste qu'
aucun des pays européens ne l'avait
anticipé et c'est cette situation vous
le savez qui nous a conduits à
décider d'un nouveau confinement comme
je lé déjà indiqué ceci dit monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés
la perspective d'une deuxième vague fait
partie à défaut de prévoir l'avenir de
l'histoire des grandes pandémies
donc évidemment ce qu'on ne connaît pas
c'est le moment elles surviennent et
l'ampleur qu'elles ont mais on va dire
que l'idée qu'une deuxième vague pouvait
se produire était connue de tout le
monde et le risque que d'un requin
finement dans lequel nous nous trouvons
et être prévu anticipé et d'ailleurs je
tiens à votre disposition le rapport que
j'avais écrit lorsque je m'occupais du
déconfinement où j'ai indiqué très
clairement que cette situation pouvait
se produire
donc nous y sommes et nous avons mis en
oeuvre notamment s'agissant du système
hospitalier j'aurais sans doute là
l'occasion d'y revenir
les dispositions
qui était prévu en pareilles
circonstances du coup je viens et je
serais même de détailler toutes les
mesures qui ont été prises pendant tout
l'été et jusqu'à aujourd'hui si votre
commission le souhaite bien entendu
du coup je viens à votre troisième
question monsieur le président qui est
qui concerne plutôt la gestion
territorialisée de la crise en tout cas
c'est comme ça que je les comprise avec
le couple préfet maire les relations ars
préfet donc il me semble qu'il ya deux
questions là aussi dans une il ya la
dévolution des compétences au sein de
l'appareil d'état qui fait quoi dans les
territoires corps où nous avons
effectivement et c'est bien antérieure à
la crise des agences régionales de santé
qui comme leurs noms l'indiquent en des
missions à caractère régional et qui
sont donc on pourrait dire les services
s'est pas tout à fait exact évidemment
droit déconcentrés du ministre du
ministère de la santé
et puis l'administration préfectorale
vous avez cité les préfets qui eux sont
les représentants du gouvernement et de
l'ensemble des lycées qui notamment ont
un rôle plus marqué lorsqu'il s'agit de
la crise le préfet et les ars de mon
point de vue ont globalement travailler
de manière satisfaisante m'est arrivé de
les réunir ensemble ou séparément la
difficulté et vous le savez c'est que
les ars sont organisées au niveau
régional et interdépartemental qui est
peu développée mais ça c'était
antérieures à la crise alors que la
gestion de la crise suppose une action
de proximité plutôt dévolue aux préfets
de département il est clair se présente
que ça fera partie des enseignements
structurelle à tirer de ça mais
évidemment quand mon processeur comment
même gérant dans l'urgence une crise il
est impossible de comment dire de
remédier à cette organisation
en chemin en cours de route ce sera
encore plus des stabilisateurs donc nous
avons veillé à ce que les uns et les
autres travaillent au mieux et que là le
niveau départemental en particulier par
l'intermédiaire des préfets de
département soit les plus impliqués
possible dans la gestion de la crise et
c'était d'autant plus nécessaire j'en
viens à votre deuxième question qui
effectivement dès lors que nous avons
une gestion territorialisée qui implique
ces deux acteurs adresse et préfet il
faut agir vous travaillez avec les
collectivités territoriales
vous avez cité le couple le couple
maires préfets si on voulait être très
précis il ya le maire je dirais aussi
les présidents et présidentes pardon
d'agglomération ou de structures
intercommunales
je vais revenir dans un instant mais il
ya aussi les régions et départements qui
à un titre ou un autre ont joué dans la
gestion de cette crise un rôle plus ou
moins important il n'empêche
effectivement à partir du moment où nous
avons décidé comme je l'indiquais tout à
l'heure que il y avait une gestion de
territorialiser donc avait des actions
différencier jusqu'à ce que la pandémie
reprennent de manière vive ou là on a
été obligés de prendre des mesures
uniforme sur l'ensemble territoire
national il fallait s'appuyer sur ce que
vous avez appelé le couple maires
préfets c'est à dire une association une
participation des collectivités
territoriales gestion de la crise je
précise toutefois à votre commission que
nous sommes dans une crise sanitaire et
que là aussi peut-être que vous en tirer
des enseignements plus structurelle mais
la police sanitaire et même j'allais
dire la politique sanitaire relève
ça n'a pas commencé avec la crise à
cauville de l'état
vous apprends rien n'a non plus donc ça
signifie que un dernier ressort
en cas de désaccord s'il ya des
difficultés etc
c'est évidemment à l'état de prendre ses
responsabilités et j'observe du reste
que c'est ce que souhaite quand même les
collectivités locales elles souhaitent
être associés mais elle ne souhaite pas
évidemment que l'état se défausse de ses
responsabilités sur elle et je crois que
ça n'a jamais été le cas je voudrais sur
ce registre témoigner que si évidemment
il ya eu un certain nombre de
difficultés avec les collectivités
locales je ne parle pas de la période
encore antérieures sur la question
d'acquisitions des masques je maintiens
à ce qui était de ma responsabilité on
l'a vu par exemple pour les décisions de
fermeture d'un certain nombre
d'établissements recevant du public je
pense en particulier aux bars et aux
restaurants dans certains territoires
on l'a vu encore dans la période récente
avec la question de la fermeture des
commerces qui ne vendent pas des
produits de première nécessité il ya eu
certain nombre de difficultés
globalement globalement les choses se
sont passées de façon satisfaisante et
continue de se passer de façon
satisfaisante et je m'emploie à veiller
à ce que ça se passe de façon
satisfaisante
je voudrais faire juste un focus sur les
métropoles
pourquoi ce les métropoles parce qu'on
est au coeur me semble utile delà de la
gestion de la crise épidémique où on
voit bien pour des raisons que chacun
comprendra des fortes concentrations de
population la commune
quand elle est dans une zone urbaine
dense et les frontières communales
n'arrête pas le virus
donc c'est bien une gestion
métropolitaine que qui
à laquelle il faut procéder là aussi
c'est ce que font je les observe la
plupart des pays qui nous entourent
donc avec avec ces métropoles alors ce
fut uniquement à la fois parce qu'il y
en a évidemment moins que les 36000
communes
je me suis personnellement investi
auprès de beaucoup d des présidentes et
présidents de ces métropoles tout au
long de la crise
encore maintenant et que je voudrais
devant votre commission le leur dire que
au delà de ce qu'on peut lire ou
entendre ici ou là les relations n'ont
jamais été rompus ont toujours été
fluide il ya pu y avoir des différences
d'appréciation dieu merci mais que in
fine et je dirai les choses se passent
bien je m'aime je le précise à votre
commission pour à marseille où il est
simple à personne qu'à un moment donné
il ya pu avoir quelques tensions dont
chacun se souvient jeu j'ai tenu à me
rendre en laissant passer un peu de
temps pour ramener le calme la sérénité
à marseille j'ai été reçus par madame la
maire de marseille et madame la
présidente de la métropole
nous avons discuté nous continuons de le
faire et j'allais dire les relations
sont comment dire stabilité sont des
relations de confiance pour faire face à
la pandémie
donc voilà leleu
l'association des collectivités des
métropoles est effectivement vous l'avez
vous avez aussi posé cette question
nécessaire et ce qui va me permettre de
faire le lien avec l'avenir sur la
politique de dépistage et de tests
d'accord puisque évidemment là aussi je
retiens bien leur préciser à votre
commission et à l'ensemble de de celles
et ceux qui nous écoutent la politique
de test est une politique sanitaire et
donc il est indispensable que là la
doctrine de test déploiement du
dépistage où qu'il se trouve soit sous
la supervision sur la conduite en vrai
le terme que vous voudrez des autorités
sanitaires mais bien entendu ça n'exclut
pas puisque votre question monsieur
présents portaient sur les collectivités
territoriales que celles ci soient
associés puisse y participer
alors on voit certaines ça peut être par
l'acquisition de tests très bien le leu
leu il me semble que et nous les
africains semblent nous les avons aussi
sollicité dès le mois d'août
dès le mois d'août 1 j'ai demandé
l'élaboration de plan métropolitain
préfet président de métropole que sur ce
dépistage puisque en trente fois c'était
votre question elles puissent aussi être
associés sur l'accompagnement des
personnes qui
six hommes qui sont isolées lorsqu'elles
ont été testées positives ou qu'elles
sont qu'à contacter de ces dernières
parce que là évidemment je sais tu pas
auprès de votre commission que
j'expliquerai que les maires ou les
programmes de métropole en des époques
des populations une connaissance une des
contacts de droit commun j'allais dire
que les services de l'état qui sont pas
très nombreux malgré tout d'aller dans
les territoires n'ont pas naturellement
donc voilà le votre troisième votre
troisième question
interrogé sur ce qui va se passer sur
les mois à venir monsieur le président
vous avez commencé par parler de
vaccination massive je vous cite donc
effectivement je commencerai par vous
dire qu'il fait que nous nous mettons un
état compte tenu des perspectives qui se
dessinent et que vous connaissez que
vous entendez effectivement d'être un
état de vacciner la population française
avec d'abord la nécessité de savoir avec
qui nous allons vacciner quelle quelle
personne les autorités sanitaires et
scientifiques
recommanderont de vacciner en priorité
et puis bien entendu toute
l'organisation logistique on va dire que
va représenter cette opération
extrêmement importante et à laquelle
nous préparer votre question allait
évidemment au delà nous sommes en train
de bâtir essais le mans vous dire c'est
la difficulté de cette épidémie c'est à
dire que nous adaptons au fur et à
mesure de ce qui est constaté dans les
les dernières caractéristiques de la
vague épidémique
donc nous ajustons en permanence on voit
bien que
la phase suivante va devoir à la fois
accroître les politiques que je viens
d'évoquer de tests de dépistage ce qui
sera rendue possible par l'arrivée d'une
nouvelle génération de tests vie
antigénique voilà mais qu'il a aussi su
poser et tous les pays européens ont des
difficultés avec ça et ne une lourde
organisation logistique qui va encore
une fois vous en connaissez toutes les
trois les trois dimensions puisqu'il
s'agit à la fois de tester mais aussi
d'alerter et de protéger les personnes
testées positives et leur cas contacts
et puis des mesures on va dire de
freinage pour comme andy éviter le stop
and go qui fort des expériences que nous
avons eu jusqu'ici nous permettront
peut-être de d'être plus ajustée donc on
fera évidemment les les annonces et
décision dès que nous aurons calais le
dispositif parce que la priorité des
priorités aujourd'hui pour le
gouvernement et je pense l'ensemble de
la nation c'est de réussir l'actuelle
phase de déconfinement de confinement
pardon et qui est très importante le
président de la république a fixés vous
le savez une échéance le 1er décembre
prochain
donc à cette échéance il faut que grâce
aux mesures de freinage qui ont été
prises
les taux d'incidence continue d'être
orienté à la baisse en tout cas une
progression moindre que les services de
réanimation
ne sois plus saturés vous avez observé
tout ce qu on atteint difficilement
palier donc il faut le consolider donc
vraiment si vous voulez toute notre
énergie doit être tournée vers la
réussite de phase actuelle pour bien le
préparer la suivante parce que il faut
expliquer aux françaises et aux français
au delà de 2 de votre assemblée que plus
vite faire mieux la phase actuelle de
confinement produira ses effets en
termes sanitaires j'entends plus nous
pourrons évoluer et passer à une phase
suivante mais mais j'achève de donnez
pas votre question qui ne sera pas le
retour à l'entée confinement c'est à
dire que il y aura des discussions de
freinage sont en cours de calage qui
perdureront soit pour certains faire
payer soit pour cette parce que la
situation se sera améliorée mais pas
suffisamment et puis surtout parce pour
éviter qu'il y ait trop d'écart entre
une période de confinement une période
de déconfinement l'idée c'est de pouvoir
gérer un peu plus dans la durée nous
espérons toutes et tous ici évidemment
que les vaccins d'une part pour se
déployer vite et surtout qu'ils seront
efficaces
j'ajouterai et qu'il y sera recouru par
nos concitoyens il ya quand même trois
conditions donc comme tant que je n'ai
pas la certitude que ces trois
conditions seront remplies il est de mon
devoir et le devoir de l'état pardon de
d'organiser une gestion au long cours je
termine en vous disant qu' il faut
absolument faire que votre commission
est bien la conviction mais vous l'avez
dit monsieur le président que le
gouvernement de la république évidemment
évidemment a parfaitement conscience
d'une part que plus le temps passe plus
c'est difficile à supporter acceptée par
le corps social c'est tout à fait normal
de vie des français supporte moins bien
la deuxième phase que la première fois
oui justement il ya c'est bien parce
qu'il ya une première phase qui a été
dur qu'il ya surprise tout le monde on
accepte une force de résilience et puis
plus les mois passent plus la crise dure
et s'installent plus là supportabilité
est faible c'est parfaitement humain est
normal et donc nous nous devons de
prendre toutes les mesures
d'accompagnement possible économique et
social et là encore je le dis mais je
suis prêt de détailler devant votre
commission toutes les mesures que nous
avons prises depuis le premier
confinement c'est à dire depuis en
réalité l'arrivée de la pandémie en
france le gouvernement de montrer ses
soeurs comme le mien montrent que nous
n'avons pas lésiné sur ces mesures
d'accompagnement que nous nous les avons
même accru dans la phase actuelle
précisément parce que nous savons bien
que la crise économique qui résultent de
cette crise sanitaire peut aussi a aussi
des conséquences extrêmement lourdes
extrêmement délétère extrêmement
difficile et vous l'avez vu nous avons
choisi de faire un deuxième confinement
tenant précisément compte du premier
avec une différence majeure mais que
votre assemblée connaît parfaitement
qu'ils aient le choix que nous avons
fait après analyse approfondie du
premier confinement de ne par confiner
le système éducatif choix lourd
important qu'on fait la plupart des pays
qui l'entourent pas tous à tous il y en
a quand même qui ont refermé les écoles
pour le dire mais une majorité comme
nous
pas fait ce choix parce que nous avons
tiré comme conclusion du premier
confinement que les bilans qu'aux
avantages y compris sanitaire de la
fermeture des établissements scolaires
militait pour qu'on les laisse ouvert
même si nous savons par conséquent que
ça amène un peu plus de gens forcément à
sortir de chez eux et que donc là les
effets de se re confinement s'en
trouverait nécessairement amoindri ça
c'est évident donc je répète à tout à
tous encore il faut faire pédagogique
je sais que les députés le savent en
déconfinement pour faire simple on va où
on veut mais les lieux de destination
sont assortis de protocole sanitaire
plus ou moins strict ce cas des
entreprises tout cas d école c'est le
cas des commerces salle de soin etc en
confinement
on reste chez soi on limite au maximum
les lieux de destination de travail les
établissements scolaires je viens d'en
parler et les commerces de première
nécessité tout le reste on n'y va pas
pour éviter les flux les sorties les
interactions la question n'est plus de
savoir tout le monde l'aimait oui mais
sont dotées de deux protocoles sert bien
sûr mais on est passé à une logique
préventive
il s'agit pas de stigmatiser les lieux
on ne peut plus aller ils font les
efforts tous les efforts qu'il faut et
même il faut évidemment les indemniser
puisqu'un appel
l'idée c'est bien on limite au maximum
les occasions de sorties est
effectivement combien les écoles en plus
dans ces occasions par rapport au
premier confinement là il faut être
extrêmement strictes sur tout le reste
pour que ce confinement puisse produire
ses meilleurs effets sans contrepartie
ou avec des contreparties on va dire
parce qu'il y en a toujours
il y en a toujours les mieux maîtriser
possible merci beaucoup je crois
qu'effectivement cette notion hautement
médical du rapport bénéfice/risque doit
diriger nos décisions
en permanence je passe la parole à
monsieur le rapporteur merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
merci naturellement de votre présence
importante devant notre mission et nous
sommes sensibles aux réponses que nous
apporter nous mesurons la difficulté de
la tâche nous nous l'ignorons pas même
si notre devoir est de poser souvent des
questions que se posent les français
sans esprit polémique et en n'ayant ni
la volonté de nous transformer en
tribunal populaire ni encore moins en
tribunal judiciaire ce qui je crois est
particulièrement inopportun dans la
période
je voudrais vous interrogez à la fois
sur le passé et sur le présent tout cas
sur le passé récent nous avons dans
notre commission auditionnés c'était le
18 juin date un peu symbolique
les membres du conseil scientifique qui
pour la plupart nous ont assez
clairement annoncé une seconde vague
elle nous a été aussi annoncé par le
professeur flahault je crois que c'était
dans une audition tout début septembre
quand nous avons repris nos travaux et
on voit bien que début septembre
tous les indicateurs se dégrade et votre
ministre de la santé avait lui même eut
tenu des propos alarmistes dix ans le 5
septembre s'attendre à une augmentation
forte d admission en réanimation
et la presse se faisait état aussi de
votre côté d'une analyse assez
pessimiste de l'évolution de la
situation avec plusieurs centaines de
nouveaux cas par jour dans les premières
semaines de septembre
tout cela vous conduisant à un conseil
de défense présidée par le président de
la république le 11 septembre suivie par
une conférence de presse de votre part
je crois en fin d'après-midi le 11
septembre et qui a été annoncé par la
presse comme devant marqué l'adoption de
mesures restrictives forte est assez
forte
or ces mesures ne sont pas venus dans
votre propos en tout cas le 11 septembre
il n'y a pas eu de décision ni de couvre
feu ni encore moins de confinement
première question est ce que quelque
part il n'y a pas eu un temps de retard
dans la prise de décision il y a des
voix forte qui se sont exprimés je cite
le professeur dominique costagliola ce
jour-là disant je ne peux m'empêcher
penser que c'est une occasion manquée
prendre les choses de façon précoce est
toujours plus efficace si j'ai de l'eau
à la taille je dois m'en sortir avec une
solution qui agissent viste avec alors
qu'avec de l'eau cheville je peux faire
quelque chose de moins drastiques
je pense aussi à la déclaration de de
notre prix nobel d'économie esther duflo
qui prônait un confinement préventif dès
le 2 octobre donc est-ce que
rétroactivement mais bon c'est plus
facile de le dire aujourd'hui j'en
conviens il n'y a pas eu un temps de
retard dans dans cette prise de décision
qui nous aurait pu qui aurait pu nous
éviter les déboires que l'on connaît
dans la mesure où l'on voit et vous avez
raison de le souligner monsieur le
ministre monsieur premier ministre par
donc que les mesures qui ont été
adoptées ont manifestement un effet
positif et bien entendu on s'en réjouit
que ce soient les mesures de couvre-feu
ou ou de confinement que personnellement
j'ai approuvé et soutenu à titre tout à
fait
personnel donc est ce que il n'ya pas ce
temps de retard
et puis sur l'anticipation de cette
deuxième vague beaucoup de nos
concitoyens se demande aussi notamment
sur ce qui a été fait pendant l'été qui
a été fait depuis la première vague pour
tirer les leçons de ce que nous avons
subi en mars avril notamment sur
l'adaptation de notre système de santé
nos deux systèmes hospitaliers puisque
en gros nous connaissons les mêmes
contraintes sur les lits de réanimation
et nous sommes à nouveau contraints à
des problématiques très graves liés à la
déprogrammation des soins orco vide qui
sera sans doute peut-être à terme une
des conséquences les plus graves de la
terrible crise qui a déjà emporté 45
mille de nos concitoyens mais qui
pourrait malheureusement et ça a été dit
devant notre commission en emporter
d'autres sur la conséquence de cette
déprogrammation d'actes médicaux comme
des dépistages et j'évoquais hier avec
le président le cm du chu nice des actes
de des pros crasse mination qu'il
regrettait sur des coloscopies
préventive qui sont retardés de
plusieurs mois donc la question de 2,7
de cette anticipation ce mot
anticipation il est au coeur de nos
travaux voilà est ce que on a
suffisamment dissipées en temps voulu
une question aussi monsieur le premier
ministre sur la gestion de la crise est
un peu le sentiment et notamment cette
semaine
sujet plus global qui qui concerne le
début de la gestion de cette crise
également de de la question de savoir
qui est le pilote le commandant en chef
de cette guerre telle qu'elle a été
dénommée dans les premiers jours par le
président de la république et quand on
voit
semble-t-il mais peut-être que vous me
contredirez le sentiment que vous n'êtes
pas en tout cas que le ministre de
l'économie et pas totalement en phase
avec vous sur la question de la
réouverture des commerces et de cette
date on a un peu le sentiment que ce
pilotage reste au coeur des difficultés
qu'on ressent dans cette crise et enfin
monsieur le président de la commission
on l'a déjà abordé donc je serais assez
brève sur l'avenir parce que c'est ce
qui nous intéresse commencera armée pour
éviter cette troisième crise et comment
surtout on en sortira définitivement
troisième vague éventuel comment on en
sortira définitivement grâce sans doute
au vaccin
comment se prépare à l'arrivée de ce ou
de ces vaccins comment on anticipe
l'encore toute une chaîne logistique
est ce qu'il y a une une stratégie qui
est d'ores et déjà établi sur la
première vague on a eu un peu le
sentiment que c'était l'échec des
masques sur la deuxième que c'était
l'échec des tests
il faut que sur l'avenir ce soit la
réussite des vaccins en tout cas c'est
notre souci est comment vous y préparer
pu enfin une question vraiment de
dernière minute comme on pourrait dire
je vois que le figaro annonce des
mesures prises par le président de la
république que vous seriez conduit à
annoncer la semaine prochaine sur un
couvre-feu qui se substituerait au
déconfinement est ce que tout ça est est
sur la table est ce que c'est réel est
ce que ce sont des hypothèses de travail
à ce stade peut-être j'imagine voilà
monsieur le premier ministre
quelques questions un peu large et vaste
en vous remerciant pour vos réponses je
commence juste peut-être par la fin et
celle sur le pilotage la de l'actualité
j'invite peut-être la commission à
s'intéresser ce qui est déjà aux
décisions prises
parce que si on commence à discuter sur
qui pensent quoi qu'est-ce qui est sur
la table passion table enfin leur jeu
je veux rendre compte de façon
totalement transparente ce qui est fait
mais si on rentre dans les processus de
décision qui ne sont pas prises vous
comprendrez toutes et tous que c'est
compliqué le commandant en chef alors
semble-t-il et il faut revenir à des
choses extrêmement simple nous sommes
dans une crise sanitaire avec une
constitution qui est assez claire c'est
le pouvoir exécutif de l'état je dis ça
puisque je les ai fait allusion tout à
l'heure il ya d'autres pays où la
gestion de la santé est décentralisée ou
relève d'état
au niveau fédéral bon c'est même
j'allais presque dire une majorité de
pays ça a des avantages mais aussi des
inconvénients je me suis entretenu je
vous parlais des liens avec mes
collègues et la chancelière allemande
il m'explique elle va négocier avec les
présidents des länder pour obtenir telle
ou telle décision on envie c'est quand
on se
quand on se compare on a toujours des
motifs de ceux de se rassurer parfois
bon mais en tout cas ce qui est clair
chez nous vous porterez l'appréciation
voudrait mais le fait est que cet état
qui reste sa politique celle terre voilà
et au sein de l'état le pouvoir exécutif
agit et le législateur prend des lois
lorsque elle relève de sa preuve de ces
pratiques c'est le cas vous en avez voté
quelques-unes depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire encore une très
récemment pour le
le retour de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
et puis vous exercez votre fonction de
contrôle sans faillir me semble-t-il
depuis en tout cas que je suis prêt mini
c'est l'occasion de m'en rendre compte
bon donc il ya bien pour un contrôle
mais le pouvoir de décision appartient
aux pouvoirs exécutifs et vous ferez le
scoop à vue disant que le pouvoir
exécutif sur la vème république c'est le
président de la république est derrière
lui le préfet nist son gouvernement
donc le gouvernement prépare et met en
oeuvre les décisions correspondantes
dans le cadre de ces pôles hâtives
vous avez évoqué le ministre de
l'économique effectivement un acteur
essentiel dans la gestion de la crise
sanitaire pic qu'il y a effectivement
des conséquences économiques très forte
mais on peut aussi penser à l'ami du
travail au ministre qui s'occupe des
personnes les plus vulnérables
enfin la ministre les hobbies éducation
nationale et de l'enseignement supérieur
puisqu'il ya toutes les problématiques
et les chrétiens fêtent tous les
ministres on tend rôle extrêmement
important et ce qui compte encore une
fois ce sont des décisions qui sont
prises à l'arrivée comme je l' ai déjà
dit les ministres exprime au sein de
l'appareil gouvernemental ravissent est
heureux je j'ai connu d'autres temps
sans porter ou c'était exactement la
même chose et c'est heureux comme il est
heureux qu'à la fin il y ait quelqu'un
qui décide
il s'agit du président république et du
premier ministre alors je reviens à
votre question parce que si vous
permettez
elle est tout à fait fondamental or là
parce que je suis vraiment dans le le
rôle qui est celui de vous rendre compte
donc vous avez situé dans particulier
début septembre c'était ça monsieur
ciotti votre votre question simple dames
en jeu je vous redonne je vous remets
cette courbe que je vous remettra à
toutes et à tous voilà qui était la cour
à la fois de l'évolution de l'incidence
et des hospitalisations ou effectivement
vous avez tout à fait raison
début septembre
calqué sur vous imposer voilà c'est ici
là on peut pas au milieu du graff
d'accord effectivement raison il ya une
augmentation mais qui est quand même
faible
si je vous dis ça d'avoir vous l'avez
dit vous avez bien voulu citer des
scientifiques qui aurait dit il faut
faire si vous faire là je me suis permis
d'en trouver d'autres
ciotti n'est ce pas voilà voilà oui non
non mais bon voilà je veux pas citer les
noms mais je tiens à votre disposition
un infectiologue à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière le 5 août moi je ne m'affole
pas
la létalité va être beaucoup beaucoup
plus faible beaucoup beaucoup on va
moins mourir de ce virus
un autre très célèbre le 28 août les cas
qu'ovide sont différents ils sont moins
graves
ils restent moins longtemps l'hôpital
ils sortent d'ailleurs plus souvent de
l'hôpital le 8 septembre un chef de
service de maladies infectieuses dans un
grand hôpital du sud
la mortalité liée au corona virus a
diminué
on parle de chiffres qui sont très bas
sur des patients qui sont très âgées est
très fragile enfin chercheurs
épidémiologistes très connu 10 septembre
la menace à l'heure actuelle n'existe
pas en la fabrique plus ou moins avec
des chiffres nous sommes face à une
épidémie avec 97 % de cas négatifs
je pourrais vous en sortir d'autres
votre disposition bon ça c'est pour
répondre à votre observation sur un
discours scientifique mais je pense
qu'il n'aura pas échappé à votre
commission qui n'ont jamais été
particulièrement unanime et convergents
d'ailleurs je ne saurais il ne
m'appartient pas de juger leur en
vouloir parce que j'ai compris quand je
lis la littérature de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé depuis deux mois de
janvier sur le rapporteur général
elle a aussi beaucoup évolué alors on
peut être très critique en disant mais
ils ont changé d'avis en tout cas on
peut être frappé lorsque les décideurs
publics parce qu'on aimerait bien
s'adosser à des conseils scientifiques
précis convergents unanime mais en fait
et c'est toute la difficulté de cette
épidémie
c'est par l'observation on ne passe plus
ou moins d'une vision théorique de ce
virus
à l'observation de ces dégâts partout
dans le monde pour adapter les
conséquences qu'on en tient donc
effectivement si vous cherchez à me
faire dire que nous avons substrat
scientifique évolutif et pas toujours
convergents qui n'éclaire pas
nécessairement les pouvoirs publics mais
j'allais dire qui et surtout peut-être
parfois un peu comment dire
stressant pour l'opinion publique qui
aimeraient avoir des repères et des
références comme nous tous d'ailleurs
plus sûres je prends que savez vous que
c'est une réalité
deuxièmement j'appelle votre attention
mais vous le savez nous sommes à la fois
dans un état de droit dans une
démocratie dans un état de droit sur
quant au général
nous ne pouvons prendre des décisions
surtout difficile voudrais parler de
couvre feu etc
n'auriez-vous pas dû et c'est que
lorsque je dispose de données
épidémiologiques suffisamment dégradées
pourraient vous donner la jurisprudence
du conseil constitutionnel du conseil
d'état sur tous les sujets on ne peut
prendre des mesures privatives de
liberté que lorsque l'on dispose de
données
qui dit mieux logique et encore quand on
apprit alors que la situation était
beaucoup plus dégradé des mesures
certains tribunaux
je vous le rappelle nous hante annulé et
puis surtout la démocratie c'est
l'acceptabilité je me permets de vous
rappeler maintenant je vais vous donner
des faits les réactions de l'opinion
peut-être de certains parlementaires je
n'en sais rien car nous avons pris un
somme à la démesure un peu restrictive
l'accueil n'a pas été enthousiastes
je n'ai pas souvenir d'un seul député
qu'à l'époque on nous ait dit vous n'en
fait pas assez
je vais illustrer mon propos donc j'ai
été nommé premier ministre au tout début
du mois juillet c'est à dire au moment
où en application des lois que vous avez
voté en sortait de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire c'était précisément le 10
juillet condamné sorti j'ai souhaité dès
ma prise de fonction je le rappelle ici
même proposé quand bien même nous avions
alors on est en juillet des données
épidémiologiques très faible en tout cas
par rapport à celle que nous avions en
main est celle que vous avez aujourd'hui
je pense que ça devrait je rappelle
quand même que j'ai pris le décret du 17
juillet 2020 qui n'a pas été compris par
tous étant dans l'obligation du port du
masque aux commerces aux administrations
et aux banques et aux marchés couverts
le 30 juillet j'ai pris un décret
rendant le port du masque obligatoire
sur la voie publique alors en renvoyant
en déconcentrant au préfet pour qui le
mettre dans les zones où ça leur paraît
c'est le plus nécessaire au vu des
données épidémiologiques
je rappelle que le 28 août j'ai pris un
décret étendant le port du masque
obligatoire pour tous les rp 10 à 6 les
cinémas les théâtres etc mais aussi pour
les collégiens et les lycéens alors que
la rentrée scolaire approché que à cette
même date
nous avons traduit les recommandations
du haut conseil de santé publique dans
le protocole national
pour assurer la santé et la sécurité des
salariés en entreprise c'est-à-dire
généralisant le port du masque en milieu
professionnel
nous avons pris ces dispositions est
effectivement comme il y avait encore
une augmentation de la courbe au début
du mois de septembre
je me suis exprimé vous l'avez dit le
rose
j'ai annoncé un certain nombre de
dispositions notamment l'inscription de
42 départements supplémentaires en zone
de circulation active du virus
et c'est là qu'il faut quand même être
très précis c'est à dire que comme la
gestion était déconcentré le fameux
couple maires préfets les mesures de
freinage c'est les préfets qui les ont
pris à la suite de mon annonce et
surtout je rappelle j'avais demandé dans
les trois territoires où la situation
était la plus dégradée
marseille-bordeaux la guadeloupe aux
préfets de me faire des propositions et
de prendre après concertation donc je
n'ai pas annoncé effectivement super en
démesure de freinage
c'est à ce moment là je le rappelle à
votre commission qu'à marseille le port
du masque a été rendue obligatoire ainsi
que dans 26 autres buts sur l'ensemble
du territoire de ces collectivités que
les bars et restaurants ont été fermées
à minuit je n'ai pas souvenir monsieur
ciotti qu'à ce moment là on met accusé
que ce fut trop mou que la vente
d'alcool a été interdite à 20 heures que
les vestiaires sportifs ont été fermés
que nous avons renforcé le cadencement
des transports en commun et qu'un
certain nombre de manifestations ont été
annulées notamment la foire de marseille
qui était prévu pardonnez moi je me
souviens plus exactement la date mais
quelques jours après et j'observe
d'ailleurs qu'à partir du 28 septembre
partir du 28 septembre le taux
d'incidence dans le cette région a
commencé à diminuer à bordeaux outre des
mesures de cette même nature que je ne
reviennent pas sur lesquelles je ne
revienne pas le préfet a décidé de
réduire les georges les événements de
cinq mille à mille personnes que les
rassemblements de 10 plus de 10
personnes sur les jardins les parcs mais
également les quais de bordeaux ont été
interdits ainsi que d'autres mesures qui
là aussi je le rappelle à votre
commission ont permis de limiter les
effets de l'épidémie dans
l'agglomération bordelaise
donc ce moment là nous avons pris des
dispositions qui étaient adaptés à la
fois aux circonstances locales et à la
circulation du virus tel que nous la
comprenons la suite da chronologie je
peux vous la donner au ciné ça n'était
pas exactement votre votre question le
24 septembre nous avons adopté une
nouvelle classification en classant les
départements ou les agglomérations trois
zones des hommes d' alerte les hommes d'
alerte renforcée les zones d'alerté
maximale en fonction là aussi un pardon
du taux d'incidence est déjà du nombre
de patients qu'ovide admis dans les
services de réanimation et vous savez
que c'est ce sont ces mesures qui ont
été parfois fortement contestée je ne
reviens pas sur la situation de la
fermeture des bars et des restaurants à
marseille
mais encore une fois j'ai beaucoup de
littérature sur le rapporteur général
les réactions à ces mesures n'étaient
pas pour reprendre votre formule celle
du 1 de retard de l'occasion manquée
mais au contraire des observations dix
ans que l'on en fait trop et c'est
d'ailleurs toute la difficulté de cette
gestion est d'ailleurs émanant parfois
des mêmes personnes
parfois on n'en fait pas assez parfois
on en fait trop
donc sûrement que là la vérité que je ne
prétends pas détenir se situe au juste
milieu
vous avez également posé une question
extrêmement importante sur
l'anticipation mais cette fois ci dans
le système hospitalier dans le système
sanitaire
bon là aussi et cette question peut être
me permet de faire de la pédagogie
auprès de vous tous et vous tous quand
cette crise sanitaire survient dans
notre pays il y a en france selon une
classification qui n'est pas homogène en
europe
5000 va retenir un chiffre rond c'est
pas tout à fait ça sur le rapporteur
général lits de réanimation armé
installé ce terrible c'est ce que nous
faisons avec des modalités qui se sont
améliorées depuis lors c'est essayer de
passer cette capacité en mobilisant
d'autres personnels d'autres services et
notamment ceux dans la qualification les
soins continus les le réveil ou les
soins intensifs se rapproche le plus de
la réanimation de réallouer les
ressources pour les affecter à la
réanimation
ces ressources il faut l'expliquer parce
que l'on me pose la question y compris
aux questions au gouvernement ses
ressources humaines médicales et
paramédicales sont pour la réanimation
extrêmement spécialisé et il n'est pas
possible il n'a jamais été question en
un mois deux mois trois mois six mois
d'augmenter le nombre d'infirmiers
spécialisés ou de médecin anesthésiste
réanimateur aucun pays n'a fait c'est
impossible
donc quand on passe de cinq à dix mille
nous étions prêts pour 10000 à la
première vague vous savez qu'on ne les a
pas atteints on est à nouveau prêt à
10000 pour cette vague et j'espère bien
sûr que nous ne les atteindrons pas
c'est en redéployant alors on peut être
encore plus précis m se rapporte
généralement pas simplement au sein de
l'hôpital public par une coopération
public privé
on a même fait des progrès considérables
avec les protocoles grâce à la
collaboration avec la médecine de vie
dans les cent des patients à leur
domicile alors que dans les phases
antérieures il était admis à l'hôpital
et donc on gagne à place à l'hôpital par
voie de conséquence mai
donc on peut armer jusqu'à 10000 ulli
redéployant les personnels on ne peut
pas créer de nouveaux ronde peut
évidemment pour les soutenir
faire venir des étudiants en médecine
des étudiants en pharmacie ce que nous
faisons a plaidé réserve sanitaire etc
mais des spécialistes les spécialistes
d'anesthésie-réanimation il est
absolument impossible d'en fabriquer en
six mois le président parlait tout à
l'heure de ma visite à l'hôpital de
saint-etienne jeu il n'y a pas qu'à
l'hôpital de saint-etienne je préviens
je suis allée j'étais encore à
strasbourg mais je vais le plus possible
je serai à brest j'interroge de tous ces
soignants pour leur dire voilà est-ce
que voilà est-ce qu'il est possible
puisque sommes invaincus de créer des
virées pas de l'entente du tous par la
négative
bien entendu c'est pas possible même des
des professeurs agrégés d'autres
disciplines ont du mal à se reconvertir
dans anesthésie réanimation qui est le
coeur du en revanche il ya une gestion
mutualisée des moyens dans le jeu
souligne le caractère formidable séisme
ils sont fatigués effectivement vous
l'avez dit mais il demeure motivé et
exemplaires partout où je vais alors là
que la différence avec la première vague
et vous avez tout à fait raison c'est
qu'à la première vague d'un apu
déprogrammé en masse ce qui évidemment
est beaucoup plus dolosif aujourd'hui
parce que c'est pardonnez moi c'est un
fusil à un coup
et vous avez tout à fait raison c'est
c'est dramatique mais puisque c'est
dramatique puisqu'il faut éviter de le
faire par tous moyens
il faut donc comme le mais les médecins
ne cesse de dire non pas chercher à
accroître indéfiniment les capacités de
réanimation mais faire en sorte que les
malades ne devienne pas malade pour
arriver en réanimation
d'où le confinement d'où les mesures
préventives en amont c'est extrêmement
important et je touche du bois
c'est l'effet des mesures actuelles il
faut qu'elle ait pour effet de tarir le
flux d'arrivées en tout cas de le
diminuer fortement ou en tout cas que
les sorties soient plus importantes ou
deviennent plus importantes que les
entrées en service de réanimation donc
nous avons j'ai retrouvé en préparant
cette audition tout ce que nous avons
fait tous les documents que je tiens à
votre disposition dès le mois de juillet
même avant ma nomination pour préparer
le système hospitalier à une deuxième
vague sur les bases que je viens nous
indiquent qu'il n'y avait pas de
baguette magique on ne pouvait pas
trouver d'un anesthésiste réanimateur en
un temps si court c'est impossible mais
en améliorant encore par les thérapies
par l'organisation etc
en fait on a même gagné par rapport à la
première vague on a perdu parce que
beaucoup moins des programmes et on a
gagné avec des durée moyenne de séjour
qui se sont réduites avec une fluidité
encore plus forte dans les services mais
voilà il fallait absolument arrêter le
flux parce que tous ces efforts que je
salue encore en leurs limites
j'ajoute à l'intérieur de votre
commission que j'ai évidemment veiller
ce comme le lait sur le feu à ce que le
point central ce sont les ressources
humaines mais que tous les les stocks de
matériel les stocks de matériel et c'est
extrêmement important et vous voyez ce
qui s'était passé dans la première vague
soit évidemment en quantité suffisante
avec des réserves suffisants dans
l'ensemble des établissements de soins
et sauf évidemment à ce que le regard
extérieur et à ce qu'une commission
démontre au contraire nous sommes
maintenant armé du point de vue des
matériels pour faire face un milieu
sanitaire à réanimation en anesthésie
réanimation en particulier à à la
situation présente et même au delà en
tout cas aucun problème si on devait
armée jusqu'à dix mille lits mais ce
n'est pas l'objectif
car là je vous rejoins 200% ce ciotti il
faut à tout prix éviter de mettre les
médecins dans ce dilemme éthique
consistant à choisir des patients et sa
s'cusez moi de vous dire par rapport à
ma première réponse c'est un motif
supplémentaire pour que l'ensemble du
pays respecte et appliquent ce
confinement pour casser la progression
de la vague épidémique pour baisser le
taux d'incidence pour diminuer le flux
des admissions à l'hôpital la situation
des hôpitaux est très difficile il faut
la montrer aux français elle reste
extrêmement tendue je ne voudrais pas je
le dis devant votre commission que l'
annonce d une amélioration que l'on
constate on va tout s'en réjouir c'est
l'objectif même des mesures qui ont été
prises mais il ne faudrait pas qu'elle
laisse à penser qu'on pourrait baisser
en quoi que ce soit lagarde
si vous me permettez une métaphore
rugbystique il vaudrait mieux chercher à
transformer l'essai en concentrant nos
efforts pour que le système sanitaire
puisque c'était votre votre question
soit le plus préservé possibles et
puissent effectivement comme vous l'avez
dit mme son rapporteur général continue
continue aussi parce que c'est sa
vocation à soigner les autres malades
que ceux atteints par l'aco vide assez
beaucoup monsieur reporter la dernière
fin peut-être sur la chaîne logistique
qui se prépare pas si vous voulez un jeu
quand vous dire je pense que vous
préférez juger juger sur pièce c'est
votre rôle donc que je je le présenterai
quelqu'un te se sera arrêtée mais à la
fin je je pense que vous me croirez sous
serment lorsque je vous dis que ça
concentre beaucoup de mon énergie et de
celle de l'ensemble du gouvernement
merci beaucoup je passe la parole à
monsieur havane merci monsieur le
président sur le premier ministre
d'alors quelles leçons vous tiré de la
période d'avril pour éviter un troisième
confinement la question sur notamment
sur tester tracé isolé ce n'est pas le
sentiment que sur la politique
d'isolement
on a une vraie marge de progression
quand on voit ce qui se passe dans le
one ou ailleurs et c'est peut-être pas
dans la culture encore française mais
enfin il ya une marge de progression
deux points importants aussi sur les
tests sur les tests anti génique rapide
vous avez dit foulée déployé il faut
massif y est c'est une question très
simple
est-ce que vous avez envisagé ou vous
envisagez dernière de tester de toute la
population
je lui explique notamment sur la
question des asymptomatiques ce que tu
as leur enfin ce matin jean chemise la
santé qui nous a dit mais en fait on
fait pas les asymptomatiques parce que
on a si vous voulez on n'est pas sûr on
a des faux négatifs
ok mais la vérité aussi c'est que si on
teste est asymptomatique on fait quand
même décembre le niveau de contamination
du virus et donc il ya un intérêt calme
à agir est ce que c'est un chemin sur
lequel on pourrait aller est-ce qu'on a
les capacités de production et
logistique pour le faire ou pas
troisième point
un mot sur les commerces je sais que
c'est une question sensible mais
j'entends bien ce que vous dites c'est
pas la question du règlement intérieur
dans le commerce et la protection
sanitaire a commencé à question du flux
de déplacement mais ce fut des
déplacements peut l'organiser comme on
l'a fait comme on l'avait fait sur les
marchés alimentaires pourquoi les
préfets peuvent pas régulé avec des
horaires d'ouverture avec des
aménagements dans des rues commerçantes
où il ya du monde pourquoi on peut pas
gérer ces flux avec des attestations de
proximité qu'on pourrait aller
télécharger par exemple sur stop
anticopie de pardon voilà est-ce qu'on
peut pas la travailler quelque chose qui
permet le 1er décembre au moins de dire
on our ont ré où les commerces de
proximité et enfin dernière dernière
question parce que sur le reste sur les
écoles et où vous le savez c'est quelque
chose qu'on partage on a défendu l'idée
d'un confinement avec le travail et les
écoles mais sur les commerces
il ya un sentiment d'injustice parce que
c'est aussi un travail pour eux en tant
que tel les derniers points et d'or
philippe et est venu ici il nous a
évoqué la question de la judiciarisation
de la vie politique française est la
question
la difficulté quand on est premier
ministre d'agir dans une période de
crise sanitaire face qu'à un risque
pénal qui est parfois un peu comme une
épée de damoclès est ce que vous
ressentez ça vous dans cette prise de
décision
est ce qu'on m'en donnez vous y pensez
et que finalement vous avez envie de
prendre des mesures mais que vous êtes
un peu contraint par faire ce pari se
risque à la merci monsieur match passe
la parole à monsieur vallot je vous
laisserai répondre après monsieur
premier ministre merci monsieur le
président merci monsieur le premier
ministre nous osions auditionné il ya
quelques temps vous étiez monsieur
déconfinement depuis leur premier
ministre et vous êtes d'une certaine
manière monsieur reconfirme en a besoin
de savoir ce qui s'est passé pendant
tout ce temps non seulement parce qu'il
va y avoir un 2e déconfinement mais
potentiellement une troisième vague
personne évidemment ne souhaitent
plusieurs questions monsieur pro
ministre d'abord le président de la
république avec 14 juillet indiqué que
le pays était prêt à une seconde vague
vous même vous aviez indiqué le 26 août
qui n'ait pas lieu de s'affoler
et ils vous l'avez évoqué dès le 11
septembre le conseil scientifique avait
dit la gravité de la situation et appelé
à des mesures énergiques est-ce que vous
avez pas le sentiment c'est ma première
question que il ya une sous-estimation
de la gravité de ce que pouvait être la
seconde vague et entraînant sans doute
un manque d'anticipation par ailleurs
conseiller scientifique dans son avis du
26 octobre à parler du relatif échec de
la stratégie tester tracé isolé et je
voudrais savoir quelles sont les leçons
que vous tirez de ce relatif échec
est ce que par exemple la décision de
permettre l'accès aux tests sans
ordonnance n'a pas conduit à court
circuiter les médecins libéraux
emboliser le système est finalement à
faire pour une certaine durée échec à la
stratégie qui avait été déterminé
mathema deuxième question la troisième
question à plusieurs reprises également
le conseil scientifique déplore que
pendant l'été le plan de réduction des
risques s'adresse essentiellement aux
personnes fragiles n'est pas été
suffisamment mise en oeuvre est ce que
vous pouvez expliquer s'il ya eu ou non
de en la matière un enfant et enfin
dernière question
s'agissant de la question des écoles
est ce que vous n'avez pas le sentiment
que dès septembre
il a une forme de sous-estimation de la
pandémie dans les établissements
scolaires de vecteurs que je les jeunes
pouvaient être dans la transmission de
la maladie a fortiori pouvez vous nous
dire si ce sont les chiffres du
ministère de l'éducation nationale qui
ont commandé le protocole sanitaire
maintenant que nous savons qu'ils sont
treize fois inférieur ils ont été
longtemps 13 fois inférieur à ce que
santé publique france donnait comme
estimations pour la tranche d'âge qui
est celle des enfants des enfants
scolarisés a les yeux c'est promis je
vous laisse répondre
je le promets
si vous pouvez maintenant voilà excusez
moi je disais comme dans les deux
questions il ya des éléments qui
concernait les tests je vais les évoquer
ensemble
je commence par la fin chabada dit
quelque chose ça fait juste en lisant
effectivement tester les gens c'est
important mais il faut que les gens qui
sont testés positivement et leurs
contacts soit isolé
effectivement c'est un un sujet
essentiel puisque je vous rappelle les
dames et messieurs les députés que nous
agissons dans le cadre la loi avec une
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
qui organise l'isolément des gens testés
positifs et de leurs cas contacts sur la
base du volontariat du volant d'agde
je regarde là aussi de très près ce que
font les pays européens vous m'avez
monsieur abad par les deux pays plus
lointains les revenir mais sur les pays
européens effectivement il y en a
quelques-uns minoritaires qui ont
instauré une obligation d'isolement avec
des sanctions puisque nous sommes tous
d'accord qu'il faut amplifier encore la
politique de test je ne suis pas en tant
que chef du gouvernement
rétif à ce que cette question soit sur
la table
j'appelle l'attention de chacune et
chacun sur ses incidences fortes par
rapport à notre dispositif de libertés
publiques par rapport à la jurisprudence
du conseil constitutionnel mais surtout
mais surtout pardonnez moi parce que ça
rejoint vos de questions sur la façon
effective de faire respecter cette
obligation encore les gens qui sortent
de chez eux il ya est-ce qu'on va aller
contrôler dans la rue à leur demande en
quoi une attestation de qui sont pas
positifs en fait il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup de sujets derrière que je serai
prêt à développer devant vous tirer de
ce qui se passe bien ou mal dans les
pays voisins mais voilà je veux dire que
ce sujet
soit à la faveur des phases suivantes
puisque comme vous l'avez dit l'un et
l'autre il faudra développer ce que
rendre encore une fois possible
l'apparition des tests antigénique sur
lesquels je vais revenir
ces stratégies de dépistage la question
de l' isolement des personnes au delà de
leur accompagnement social sanitaire
psychologique qui est indispensable mais
la question qui nous est posée c'est
celle d'une d'une mesure obligatoire
parce que j'ai regardé effectivement ce
qui se passe je crois que vous avez cité
la chine la bad
on pourrait parler aussi de la corée
puisque d'autres m'ont saisi valable je
me suis intéressé à ça mais voilà c'est
quand même je le dis haut représentant
la nation des systèmes où vous êtes
géolocaliser avec votre portable
si vous sortez de chez vous avec ces
voix là un cd système certes qui ont une
efficacité
voilà comment fonctionnerait-il dans
notre droit positif avec les mentalités
de nos concitoyens ce sera un vrai sujet
là pour le coup qu'il faut partager avec
la représentation nationale d'ailleurs
seule la loi
dieu merci pourrait prévoir qu'on évolue
vers de tels systèmes sous je le répète
le contrôle du juge constitutionnel
veille toutes les questions que se pose
est que je lis dans littérature et les
sont sur la table
il faudrait pas non plus que la
perspective d'un isolement obligatoire d
ainsi que certains se faire tester parce
qu'ils ont des symptômes
parce qu'on l'a aussi constaté l'envoyée
ce président en toute transparence je
n'écarte absolument pas votre suggestion
est déjà posée je me permets à toutes et
à tous de vous renvoyer à la décision du
conseil constitutionnel du 11 mai 2020
qui ne concernait pourtant que la
transmission la transmission ne se perde
son rapporteur général des données
issues des tests vers les équipes issues
de l'isolément visiblement on est bien
d'accord si on veut
a fortiori obliger quelqu'un à s'isoler
et respectés et veiller à ce que cette
obligation soit respectée encore faut-il
que ceux qui en sont chargés sachent
qu'une personne etc ont vite plus ce qui
je vous rappelle renvoie au secret
médical en fait c'était donc ça va nous
avons là des sujets me semble-t-il
extrêmement structurants qu'encore une
fois le le gouvernement rejette pas du
tout mais qu'il faut aborder dans tout
les dimanches dans toute leur dimension
sanitaire juridique
j'allais presque dire philosophique qui
ne sont pas négligeables et qui de toute
façon là je le dire de façon très claire
le ne peut être tranchée ça tombe bien
je puis dire que je sois ici
internationale que par le législateur
que par logiciel alors maintenant vous
je vais rentrer dans d'autres
considérations
effectivement incontestablement là aussi
rendant compte de mon action devant la
commission de l'assemblée nationale
effectivement la question de la
logistique de l'organisation et tout ça
mérite d'être posée parce
qu'effectivement plus honte est
massivement monsieur abad a même parlé
d'une perspective de tester toute la
population il faut que tous suivent
alors grâce au test antigénique avec
certaines limites séquelles je
reviendrai il ya un verrou qui peut
sauter c'est celui de la disponibilité
enfin du temps de disponibilité du
résultat qui a été vous le savez lundi
l'une des difficultés que nous avons
rencontrées au mois de septembre
entre les prises de rendez-vous et les
le délai de disponibilité des tests il y
a eu effectivement un certain nombre de
difficultés
je vais y revenir mais on est obligé
plus on va développer des tests de
d'avoir une organisation quasiment
industriels sur toute la chaîne
effectivement que nous préparons
j'invite
m votre commission ce qu'elle fait un
travail de contrôle à être bien attentif
quand même sur le fait qu' on est loin
monsieur hamad effectivement de tester
toute la population mais on est quand
même parmi les pays qui testons le plus
d'europe et je n'ai pas encore ce
chiffre mais je le donnerais volontiers
la commission même dans la période
derrière nous où effectivement il ya un
écart de temps trop long entre si je le
cumul la prise de rendez vous pour se
faire tester et la disponibilité du
résultat qui du coup donné à cet
exercice une valeur nulle puisque
c'était trop tard pour isoler la
personne bien et donc on a été jusqu'à
presque allez on va dire qu'on peut
presque enlevé 40 à 45% des tests alors
pratiqué mais si je prends le volume des
tests qui étaient pratiqués à cette
période et que j'allais você 40% dans
les restes étaient dans les clous si
vous me passez secteur si je compare
avec le nombre de tests pratiqués
apporter à la population dans les autres
pays européens
mais nous restons nous restons dans des
proportions tout à fait satisfaisante
donc l'objectif est lancé on est rentré
dans le rang vous avez vous me posez la
question est-ce que keita ci qu'est ce
que la fin de la prescription médicale
n'a pas eu pour effet 2 oui oui bon
maintenant je vous rappelle qu'elle
était sans fondement qui n'est pas sorti
comme ça
l'objectif c'était d'avoir de pouvoir
tester les asymptomatique et je vous
rappelle que ceux qui recourent teste
encore aujourd'hui ces trois c1 car
simplement de gens qui visaient des
symptômes que nous avons priorisé pour
faire face aux problèmes logistiques que
vous avez évoquées donc les
symptomatique en rapidement été testés
dans des délais satisfaisants mais
le recours fait le non recours à la
prescription médicale a eu pour effet et
pour objet de faire tester des
asymptomatiques dont on ne savait pas du
tout même eux mêmes qu'ils étaient
porteurs du virus bon et je pense qu'il
faut surtout conserver cet équilibre
dont la politique de tests que
redéployer outre je n'y reviens pas les
questions liées à un isolement qui est
une vraie question à monsieur badge
existe vous vous avez posé une question
tout à fait pertinente c'est d'augmenter
au maximum la politique de test toute la
population c'est voilà ce serait une
gageure 1 et puis toute la population là
je lis aussi la littérature ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'on on isole presque
complètement même si on le fait sur une
ville je crois que c'est une question
que vous m'avez posée soit vous le
faites ça ça peut être intéressant avisé
populationnelle ou épidémiologiques
c'est-à-dire pour mieux connaître le
virus lui se situe dans quel quartier
etc
soit vous le faites dans une finalité
curative c'est-à-dire tous les cas
positifs des contacts sont strictement
isolé et cetera parce qu'effectivement
si on les isole en théorie complètement
et leur cas contact jusqu'à ce que les
symptômes disparaissent ou qu'il soit
guéri ou hospitalisés selon les cas
c'est une façon et vient de briser
l'épidémie mais à ce moment là voilà
qu'est ce qu'on fait autour de la ville
pour pas que des gens entrent ou sortent
parce qu'évidemment sinon vous faut
c'est complètement l'exercice
donc les tests antigénique vont nous
permettre encore une fois d'accroître la
politique de test des conditions qui
seront précisées justement pour préparer
c'était votre première question monsieur
le président 2
2 comment dire
de la phase post 1er décembre mais on a
déjà vous l'avez vu expérimenté au
dessus des avis et des recommandations
de la chaise pour utiliser les tests
antigénique ce qui est certain c'est que
les tests antigénique ne se
substitueront pas aux tests pcr parce
qu'ils n'ont pas tout à fait la même
portée et la même certitude qu'on va
faire un complément sur la base des
recommandations des autorités
scientifiques avec différents niveaux de
déploiement qui seront que quand ils
sont déjà que déjà été précisé suite le
premier avis de la has et que nous
allons essayer de déployer encore plus
massivement dans une deuxième phase dès
lors je le répète bien que nous serons
en capacité de tracer les grands contact
bon là c'est le rôle de l'assurance
maladie pour l'essentiel on a renforcé
les moyens et le traçage et maintenant à
peu près performant et d'isoler de façon
encore plus efficace
les personnes qui auront été ainsi
tester donc le dépistage de masse nous
attendent or je le dis pour finir pour
bien répondre au présent abad un avis du
conseil scientifique pour voir dans
quelles conditions nous pourrions y
aller vous m'avez posé une question sur
les commerces
c'est un sujet extrêmement d'actualité
vous comprenez bien toutes et tous
je répète ce que j'ai dit si vous
reconfirmer il faut limiter les flux il
faut limiter les flux si je dis en comme
au premier confinement il ya une
exception pour aller travailler
travailler j'ai bien des commerces à la
évidemment mais comme lieu de
destination sur le travail deuxièmement
pour aller à l'école ou au collège ou au
lycée
troisièmement pour aller pour jeu
pardonnez moi je vais aller à
l'essentiel pour se nourrir d'où la
notion de produit ou de commerces de
première nécessité
c'est pardonnez moi c'est déjà pas mal
comme exception au confinement plus vous
ajoutez d'exception y compris dans les
conditions que vous avez dit surtout en
situation de sanitaires dégradés
pardonnez moi ce n'est plus un
confinement ce n'est plus un confinement
et donc va pas s'étonner que ça ne
produit pas les effets d'un confinement
alors bien sûr il faut prendre en
considération toutes les professions
notamment celles que vous avez cités je
pense quand même vous l'avez d'ailleurs
reconnu comme est le paquet et oui il ya
une perspective sur lequel on travaille
qui est de dire effectivement mais je
pense que je les ai toujours dit je vais
encore dire ma conférence de presse si
les indicateurs épidémiologique suivent
la tendance qui est la leur aujourd'hui
alors effectivement à cette échéance
autour du 1er décembre c'était
d'ailleurs me semble-t-il sens de votre
question avec des protocoles améliorées
de gestion de flux et c'est parce qu'on
sera passer à une deuxième phase
parce que les indicateurs épidémique se
seront améliorées
on pourra effectivement envisagé de
rouvrir les commerces qui ne sont pas de
première nécessité je rappelle quand
même aussi que par rapport à la première
vague
nous avons décidé ce qui n'était pas le
cas de fermer un certain de rayon dans
les grandes surfaces pour assurer
l'équité entre les commerces
oui alors je sais que tout ça a été
critiqué mais bon nous assumons ce choix
nous assumons ce choix à la fois parce
que ça nous paraît un choix d'équité et
ensuite parce que bien là aussi c'est
cohérent si vous n'avez pas tous les
rayons ouverts dans une grande surface
vais ça limite les flux et les
interactions
donc c'est la réponse que je peux faire
je sais que c'est difficile c'est les
commerçants de proximité pardonnez moi
je vous le dis aux uns et aux autres
jeux je les connais bien je sais leur
importance dans la vie sociale
je sais que ce qu'ils veulent c'est pas
dead c'est travailler de leur travail de
ces vivre de leur travail
je le sais parfaitement je connais par
coeur comme jamais leur heure et c'est
donc c'est extrêmement difficile de
prendre ces mesures
je vous en expliquer le fondement side
il ya d'ailleurs pas que la france qui
fait ça donc le souci c'est de respecter
ça jusqu'à ce qu'on puisse passer à
l'étape suivante et assurer
l'indemnisation des pertes de chiffre
d'affaires que nos mesures entraînent
pour et j'appelle vraiment au sens des
responsabilités pour qu'on puisse y
arriver tout en comprenant parfaitement
la colère les critiques etc
je suis là pour ça mais la sécurité
sanitaire
avant toute chose c'est ma position et
je la maintiens pas tellement ça me
donne l'occasion de vous parler de la
judiciarisation jeudi leur donnez moi
mais si je commence à penser à ma
responsabilité personnelle ou pénales je
voyais et je ne suis pas sûr que je
prendrai l'aider